para el 18 de marzo de 2020 más de 250
millones de personas en europa estaban
confinadas sólo cinco días después reino
unido se unió a ellos para explicar el
retraso las figuras del gobierno
hablaron polémicamente de querer evitar
la fatiga de comportamiento mientras
ponían sus esperanzas en las pruebas
masivas en abril se supo que los
millones de pruebas anticuerpos
compradas a china no funcionaban y los
hospitales estuvieron al borde de
quedarse sin suministros después de
cuatro días en cuidados intensivos con
el propio virus boris johnson le dijo a
la nación que la tendencia está
cambiando y pittsburgh away físico
silent si este virus si fuera un
asaltante físico un asaltante inesperado
e invisible que por mi experiencia
personal puedo decirles que lo es este
es el momento en que hemos comenzado
juntos a luchar contra el wigan siquiera
to witch judo club el verano vio cambios
con respecto al porte de mascarillas y
el gobierno finalmente recomendó su uso
después de dudar inicialmente de la
evidencia de que funcionaban se abandonó
la aplicación de rastreo de contactos
prometida como parte
de lo que johnson dijo sería una
operación de rastreo global y a finales
de septiembre se le dijo a la ciudadanía
que trabajase desde casa si podían un
cambio de sentido
respecto al aconsejado anteriormente
inglaterra entró en un bloqueo nacional
a principios de noviembre semanas
después de que los asesores científicos
pidieran uno antes de cambiar a un
sistema escalonado en diciembre con los
planes de medidas relajadas durante la
navidad frustrados por una nueva
variante del virus que se propaga más
rápidamente ahora que el país entra en
otro confinamiento este viene acompañado
por un rayo de esperanza el reino unido
fue el primer país en aprobar una vacuna
contra el cob y 19 y ahora ha aprobado
dos de ellas ya se están entregando y la
inoculación avanza con rapidez